irène chagnaud propose voyage sans
passeport
et
dans les antilles chez qui prime ce qui
demeure de soul cher folklore peut-être
que nulle part ailleurs dans le monde
pour gunther aucun pays les cochers
riche en rythmes et en musique
là sur cette terre en liesse de crédit
date une désir relativement brand les
pizzas ci puisqu'elle compte 650
millions ce qui importe of spain la
capitale et à port of spain on croise à
travers les visages les physionomies
rencontrés dans les rues de la ville
toutes les races du monde qui se sont
mêlés
noirs blancs jaunes fia ici le village
chinois est important tout un quartier
sur les maisons on retrouve l'écriture
chinoise et on a parfois l'impression de
se retrouver à hong kong ou à singapour
les rues sont animées et si les chinois
sont nombreux les ados ne sont pas moins
ici on s'habille avec des sa vie comme
en inde
là tous les voyageurs du monde se
donnent rendez-vous pour goûter le
charme et du folklore des îles
on
trinidad est sans nul doute l'idée
calypso mais les normes sont accompagnés
lors qu est recomposée de curieuses
instrument que l'on ne trouve nulle part
ailleurs à moins que vous décidiez d'en
faire vous même c'est assez simple ce
sont des steel band ces instruments ne
sont autres que les bidons d'essence des
fut pris dans le garage le plus proche
lorsque le flux des sens et essai entier
il donne des nôtres passent et plus on
le découpe en rondelles puis les notes
de vienne pq et c'est ainsi qu'avec une
dizaine de vidéos vont constituer un
orchestre entier le show pour les
agréables et ressemble un peu aux notes
base d'un piano du reste jugez vous même
ce jour là le steel band l'accompagnait
plusieurs danses typiquement antillais
la première était une djouba ses
danseurs ses musiciens ne sont pas
encore les professionnels sans doute
cela viendra t'il avec le succès dans la
journée ils sont employés une
travailleurs dans une entreprise voisine
deux fois par semaine ils se réunissent
à 1,6 et il faut reconnaître que les
antillais sont extrêmement doués pour
l'afrique mais pour la danse
les danses antillaises ont fait le tour
du monde et le calypso est
particulièrement connue
le voici dans toute sa pureté naïve les
gestes sont improvisés librement sur le
rythme le bongo vous voyez là est connu
dans toutes les îles des antilles
non
mais déjà tandis que ces lanceurs
achèvent leur part d'autres dont se
préparent les tambours commence à battre
le temps beau pour un instant va
remplacer le steel band
car cette danse ne vient pas seulement
du folklore mais les profondeurs des
vieilles croyances venus d'afrique au
temps des esclaves
cette danse est censé limer les
anciennes scène du vaudou cette curieuse
forme d'expression religieuse qui est
sans doute moins tiède guen moitié
latine
les esprits de l'ancienne afrique sont
évoqués descendent dans le corps les
danseurs
j'aurai le temps violent
le sorcier c'est ce lanceur au foulard
noué sur la tête il est capable de faire
descendre les esprits et dans les corps
de ces hommes et de ces femmes
mais il est aussi le seul capable de les
désenvoûter les tam tams honda l'été et
voilà que les styles bonne doivent
reprendre leur jeu oui mais voilà ils
sont cons peut-il athées ou soleil
tropical et il ne donne plus de notre
juste pour les accorder
c'est extrêmement simple on se contente
de les arroser avec l'eau de la piscine
voisine pour les rafraîchir la danse qui
va suivre un succès extraordinaire
c'est une danse follement amusante qui
tient de la gymnastique et du jeu
elle consiste à passer sous cette barre
que l'on rapproche petit à petit du sol
cette danse s'appelle limbo et elle est
connue dans tous les villages des îles
au début cela paraît simple vous allez
voir que ce n'est pas si facile
le limbo se dansent sur les places des
villages les jours de fête devant une
assistance nombreuse
aussi pour corser un peu le spectacle il
ya toujours une sorte de clone la
danseurs fantaisistes qui vient se mêler
à la troupe effet mille facéties avant
de se glisser sous la barre
attention c'est l'instant passionna
labarde limbo s'est dangereusement
rapproché du sol elle n'est plus guère
cac 40 cm et ce n'est plus en s'amusant
que l'on pourra passer dessous un seul
danseur y parvient et c'est le plus
grand 1 mètre 90 et voyez sans la
toucher ni avec les mains ni avec le
torse
bravo
téléspectateurs à vos bas
iwan chagnaud vous a proposé voyage sans
passeport cette émission a été réalisée
avec un film d'yves mambé defrasne est
montage
christian de megève sont michel durand
claude gilson explique jacqueline noir
et les tranches au soir dominique
paladilhe réalisation solange péters